it's so hard to pull off a film that's
just in one location yeah she'd do
beautifully I know you move around the
school but it's pretty much a central
location were there other films that you
watched that had one location and did
you note certain things that you wanted
to emulate yeah one of the big
references for us was Hunger Steve
McQueen's first narrative feature and
kind of using the tension of
claustrophobia and isolating the
audience in those spaces was something
that I think he did beautifully and
poetically in that film and then yeah
there was also you know in that choice
there was also kind of a practical
implication it ultimately allowed us
more hours of shooting because we
weren't doing company moves and and the
the days were short already so we wanted
to just work with the actors but the
community center where we filmed I feel
like had a very lived in beautiful
quality about it and we you know my DP
came on two weeks before we did Sun
charts for every room we really tried to
emphasize what the beautiful things that
we were seeing about that space in the
film
you